mariam couture est une jeune entreprise
créée à trappes
il ya un an et demi ces gérants ne
connaissait pas le monde de
l'entrepreneuriat grâce à l'association
positif planète qui accompagnent des
porteurs de projets des les quartiers
populaires ils ont réussi à se lancer
c est positif planète franche et ska est
occupée vraiment de nous assister à
travers quatre entretiens et on lui
apporte toutes les informations par
rapport aux prix comme envoyer les prix
des rideaux comme envoyer les prix des
titres et idées des coussins et là on a
réussi à monter un business plan solide
et on a réussi à acquérir grâce grâce à
ce business plan l'activité a commencé
on a réussi à acquérir un atelier grâce
à eux leur activité repose
principalement sur la création de salon
orientaux et de coussins un an et demi
après la création de l'entreprise
ils sont satisfaits c'est vraiment une
fierté parce que ça s'est fait à trappes
et il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui nous ont
vus évoluer qui nous ont vus transporté
ddd du tissu dans notre voiture
familiale et on a commencé vraiment bas
de l'échelle et quand ils voient ça ils
se disent ah ouais c'est possible on
essaie peut-être on peut on peut le
faire chaque semaine leur conseillère
vient les voir pour répondre à leurs
interrogations et les aider en 2020
l'antenne yvelinoise de l'association a
fait plus de 2 100 accompagnement et a
permis la création de 50 et une
entreprise l'objectif de positif l'année
de france c'est de redonner confiance à
toutes les personnes qui souhaitent
développer des initiatives économiques
et ce quelle que soit leur parcours de
vie et leur projet et elle sait ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui et notamment sur sur le
département des yvelines avec notre
quatre lieux de permanence actuelle
consoeur trappe mantes-la-jolie et
mantes la ville
les mureaux et poissy et l'association
aide les porteurs de projets sur
l'ensemble de la création de
l'entreprise
si les porteurs de projets
certaines techniques notamment sur le
marketing sur le la stratégie digitale
sur voilà sur pas mal de thématiques une
fois notamment du statut juridique et ça
s'est fait autant en entretien
individuel que en action collective
quatre personnes travaillent sur
l'antenne des yvelines l'association est
financée principalement par des fonds
publics comme le fonds social européen
et le département